OPERATED, SARA, JAMES,
HARMEET GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH THIS
DISCUSSION.
AND NOW AN UPDATE ON A SECOND
ONE THAT WE BROUGHT YOU LAST
NIGHT.
I EXPRESSED CONCERNS NEW ORLEANS
SAINTS QUARTERBACK DREW BREES
SUBJECTED TO WITHERING CRITICISM
FOR ANSWERING A QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT NFL PROTEST MIGHT LOOK LIKE
NEXT SEASON.
NOW, HE SAID THE FLAG SHOULDN’T
BE DISRESPECTED AND THAT HE
THINKS HIS GRANDFATHERS AS
PIONEERS WHEN HE HEARS THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
WE NOTED THAT HE HIT HAS DEEP
CHRISTIAN FAITH AND EVERYONE
SHOULD BE TREATED EQUALLY AND
WITH RESPECT AND WE NOTED THAT
HIS GENEROUS CONTRIBUTION TO
CHARITY.
NOW MY DEAR FRIEND OF DREW BREES
LED TO ONLINE COURSE OF PEOPLE
COMPARING THOSE COMMENTS TO
PREVIOUS COMMENTS I MADE TO
LeBRON JAMES.
NOW, AT THE TIME, JAMES HAD SAID
THAT TRUMP "REALLY DOESN’T GIVE
A F "ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
WITHOUT DWELLING ON THE NUANCE
BETWEEN THE TWO INSTANCES LET ME
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT I BELIEVE.
WE ARE ALL CHILDREN OF GOD.
REGARDLESS OF OUR RACIAL OR
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES AND
THEREFORE, MUST BE TREATED
EQUALLY.
EVERY AMERICAN, EVERY AMERICAN.
IT HAS A GOD-GIVEN RIGHT TO
SPEAK HIS OR HER OWN MIND ON ANY
ISSUE.
I THINK IN ORDER TO HEAL AND
SHED LIGHT ON JUSTICES, OUR
COUNTRY NEEDS MORE DIALOGUE, NOT
LESS.
WE NEED MORE RESPECT, NOT
RETRIBUTION.
EMOTIONS ARE HOT RIGHT NOW.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IN TIMES LIKE
THESE, WE OFTEN FIND OURSELVES
AND I KNOW IT’S EASY TO TALK
PAST EACH OTHER, BUT RIGHT NOW,
AMERICANS, MOST OF THEM ARE
LOOKING FOR RECONCILIATION.
THAT MEANS POLITICIANS, POLICE
MEN EVEN CULTURAL FIGURES ALL
WORKING TOGETHER, ALL OF THEM.
NOW, WE ARE ALL HUMAN BEINGS.
AND FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME,